when I had the gym I did six and then I
did 30 plus turnarounds before I ever
made a single piece of content like how
you could run a gym better I feel
confident in saying like these things
work better than these ones I wanted to
over credentialize myself for whatever
content I was going to make so that I
felt like I could take whatever heat
someone was going to throw at me because
I'd be like well here's why I think that
like here's my evidence and I think that
approach has been good it just takes
longer like I could have shortcut after
one gym and been like here's how you run
a gym but like I wouldn't have known
what it looks like to go into a Latino
Market or in an Asian market or a black
market or a North Market or a South
Market or a Canadian Market or a UK
Market or you know what I mean